bioinformatics is the intersection of
informatics or the science of processing
data for storage and retrieval and
biology the study of living organisms
why should you care about bioinformatics
there are a few reasons for that even if
you're not in computer science or i.t
more and more data is being generated in
the research and biomedical fields
this includes agriculture biotechnology
and biomedical research so knowing what
kinds of data are being generated and
how it is being analyzed will bring
value to your personal career and the
ability to collaborate effectively with
others
so let's briefly talk about what is
bioinformatics
bioinformatics is a conversion of
biology
and data where both are equally
important as we will see in the next few
slides
who uses bioinformatics and who is this
form
the answer might have been statisticians
computer scientists or engineers
but the truth is that more and more
biologists and clinicians are now
expected to understand and handle their
own data
and to publish and succeed in basic and
translational research as well as
industry
in fact you can say today that biology
itself is rapidly acquiring
the characteristics of a data science
this field developed tremendously in the
last several decades
basically transforming life sciences
enabling technology and empowering
biomedical research at scale
as a result
many new discoveries that include new
treatments
diagnostic assays design strategies for
experimentation were discovered and
perfected
as a result there is a growing interest
among biologists and clinicians in data
including new types of data generation
like different types of omix
technologies
new methods of computational analysis
as well as approaches that allow us to
mine complex data to find patterns that
can explain biological phenomena
a lot of breakthroughs in bioinformatics
are a result of the growth and adoption
of high throughput technologies
these technologies generate
billions of data points on genes
proteins and other many molecules that
can characterize biological systems how
they function
and
what are the different variations from
normal
or different types of clinical
conditions that we can describe using
these techniques the data are
complicated but they're organized and
compiled into repositories that can be
systematically studied to understand
interrogate and establish trends
for many different applications
one such repository is maintained by the
national center for biotechnology
information which has a collection of
peer-reviewed articles biological data
sets and projects on a variety of topics
introduction to bioinformatics is a
program that is designed to introduce
you to these important terms and topics
so after completing the course you will
be able to see the applications of next
generation sequencing
biostatistical methods of analysis
and other computational tools that are
used to process and mine big data such
as machine learning
more importantly the program is more
than just a theoretical introduction
it's really a practical course
it will give you a sense of what types
of technologies are used and we call
them omix technologies
what kinds of analytical methods are
used by people in the industry and in
research to analyze and interrogate
these data sets and most importantly you
will have access to a portal and a
community that will support your journey
so the training program is going to be
run through this omics logic portal and
the omixlogic portal combines many
important elements that you need to
succeed as a beginner in bioinformatics
it gives students options for analyzing
a data set
based on code dependent paths or code
independent paths so you can pursue
bioinformatics by learning coding
languages like r and python or you can
choose to just understand the logic of
analysis by not necessarily dedicating
time to that the portal offers many
different ways to study biology using
data at different levels complexity
so what you will find
is a way to get started then identify a
type of data a type of omics data like
genomics epigenomics or others and then
pursue potentially a more technical
skill enrichment path that might include
coding and statistical analysis but you
can also skip those and especially focus
on projects which are publications
designed to introduce you to a real
scientific challenge that you can study
using data
you will find collections of training
modules that are organized under this
getting started collection
so the program is designed to point you
to the level of relevant resources and
complete them over the course of the
program that we are going to start
the resources will introduce
bioinformatics applications in
healthcare biomedical research
biotechnology and agriculture
provide you with a concise overview of
various biological concepts that you
need to know to understand omics data
introduce you to big data analysis using
several example data sets and expose you
to some coding in r in python so that
you are aware of how the analysis of
biological data is done behind the
scenes
this learning process will go from the
bottom the basic level of bloom's
taxonomy to the top of this pyramid
and the process goes from
understanding and remembering
terminology to then learning how to
apply these tools to use information in
new situations then draw connections
among ideas and eventually be able to
evaluate and even create new analyses
using the tools that you will be
introduced to
and these are just several examples that
lead to more in-depth review of key
topics technologies and analysis methods
so the program being an introduction
will give you
high level introduction into all of
these topics genomics such as variant
calling transcriptomics such as gene
expression analysis metagenomics
analysis of the microbiome or
communities of bacteria and viruses
epigenomics regulation of gene
expression using
non-genomic coding
and an introduction to data science how
do you apply data visualization analysis
and machine learning to study these
complex data sets and integrate them
importantly after this overview you will
be introduced to the concept of
omixlogic projects
these projects are focused around the
areas of oncology infectious diseases
neuroscience and agriculture and you
will be able to pick a project that you
can follow as a tutorial or potentially
design a project of your own after the
program is over
you will also be introduced to the t
bioinfo platform for big data analysis
where you can run analysis of large data
without any technical challenges
understand the logic of specific
pipelines and produce different usable
results that you can visually explore
and understand trends in the data that
you have
so to see the full schedule we welcome
you to stay in the session ask questions
and really go through each session so
that you can start your journey in
bioinformatics